and off we go because the san francisco
49ers after 15 days of not playing we'd
kind of forgotten about them peter they
were 3-0 which it was so weird to see
the 49ers at 3-0 with all these teams
that had five games that they had played
but game number four came on monday
night for the 49ers and it was a huge
one for that team they've reminded
everyone who they are they are the last
unbeaten team in the nfc and one of two
unbeaten teams in the nfl but
a great performance on both sides of the
ball really in all phases
275 rushing yards for the 49ers last
night matt breida he had that 80-plus
yard run right out of the cannon on the
first play from scrimmage for the 49ers
jimmy garoppolo not spectacular but good
enough you know not big number this is
the way the 49ers offense is supposed to
work balance this is what the vikings
have been striving for we saw it on
monday night true balance great passing
great running if you run well you can
pass well if you pass well you can run
well and if you throw a great defense on
top of it and they suffocated the browns
they had baker mayfield running for his
life all night long peter it was a thing
of beauty for the 49ers and we have to
take them seriously in an nfc where i
don't think anybody knows who the best
team is
look you know what it said to me last
night uh i just keep looking at roster
depth and we talked about it in the open
and in my opinion coming into this year
matt breida was the number three running
back on that depth chart behind mckinnon
and coleman
and now he comes out of the box running
23 miles an hour you know those things
just sort of wash over me mike i don't
pay much attention to it
but you know when you hear things like
that's the fastest a runner has has run
in the nfl this season when you start
hearing things like that you start
saying this is the number three running
back on the san francisco 49ers or at
least was when they thought that they
were going to have both
jared mckinnon uh and tevin coleman
healthy at the start of the year
so that tells me they've done a really
good job of building roster depth i
think the other thing last night that we
saw is that the 49ers can overcome
mistakes in the la in the first two
years of the shanahan regime they
weren't very good at that okay and they
overcame mistakes because robbie gould
last missed two field goals in a game
when mastodons roamed the earth
and so they could they could survive you
know a shaky game from a great field
goal kicker that's number two and the
third thing is and you know mike i'm
sure you talked about it a lot in the
first hour
but
i think every single team has to have
that match between offense and defense
it's why you worry about the chicago
bears right now you have to be at least
competent on both sides of the ball and
right now the san francisco 49ers
are
north of competent on offense and
they're very good on defense
isn't it coincidental and interesting
that statistically now
the top two teams in the nfl on defense
are the patriots and the 49ers the last
two unbeaten teams
yeah and i was praising the packers
yesterday as perhaps the most balanced
team in the nfc but
if we're going to consider the 49ers as
one of the best teams in the nfc we have
to consider them as one of the most
balanced because it is offense plus
defense an offensive head coach not
neglecting a critical side of the ball
and you know what look last night the
key play for me the moment where it
really turned was when
the browns were driving down 14-3 baker
mayfield has antonio callaway fresh from
a four-game suspension open at the goal
line the throw wasn't perfect and
mayfield admitted that himself after the
game but callaway did the volleyball
thing popped it up into the air it was
picked off big return next thing you
know it's 21-3 a 14-point swing and that
to me felt like the dagger that the
browns were not going to be able to move
the ball effectively enough to erase
that gap but it just does show you that
they're they're they're and i don't know
that would have made a difference if
they would have made it 14 to 10 maybe
the 49ers would have continued to
smother them the way they did but but
though that one play here that one play
there that really can cause the damn to
break in a game that maybe would have
been closer peter
yeah no question about it and i fought
mayfield for that throw callaway
probably should catch it but it's down
on the ground he made his he made his
receivers uncomfortable for much of the
night mike and i only saw half of this
game uh and then i saw the highlights
otherwise but i i
i just kept watching that game and i
kept saying man baker mayfield
really his accuracy was questionable
last night and the other thing i think
that we have to acknowledge right now
is that the cleveland browns need major
help on the offensive line
they face a stout defensive front like
they faced last night
and look and see what happens and
they just you know baker mayfield
couldn't breathe all night freddie
kitchen's got his work cut out for him
right now mike because that is a two and
three team
justifiably two and three they have been
smoked by tennessee they have been
smoked by san francisco you know and
they've lost fairly narrowly to the rams
but
it was a that was a justifiable result
so they have won two games so far
and they've only you know really been
great in one of them and that was the
ravens game
so now
you've got in consecutive weeks seattle
and new england to play
so this thing could go off the rails if
they're sitting there two and five near
the midpoint
all of a sudden everybody is jumping off
the bandwagon and the browns really are
gonna have a hard time making something
of what should have been a redemptive
season
you know the schedule softens for them
eventually they've got the steelers
twice in the bengals twice twice over
the final seven weeks of the season but
you got to make it there
and if they're done by the time we get
to week 11 and they get a chance to go
steelers dolphins steelers bengals
cardinals it's not going to matter at
that point they got to survive this
peter seahawks patriots then at the
broncos which is not going to be easy
and that bills game coming up week 10
that's one of those in april that looked
like oh we'll win that one now you look
at it you say
this is the bills they're pretty damn
good this year so the browns do have
some major work to do and aunt peter
this is a point i made last hour kind of
a weird scheduling quirk where you've
got both of the teams played that played
on monday night
they're playing the teams that played on
thursday night so they see those teams
have extra time the seahawks have extra
time to get ready for the browns who are
flying back to cleveland they got five
days to get ready for this game against
the seahawks who had extra time and the
rams have extra time to get ready for
the 49ers kind of a weird little thing
that yeah look it's impossible to cover
every base when you make the schedule
but i'm sure the browns are looking at
the same my god the seahawks have
already had four or five games to be
thinking about us and we're just getting
started on this one
no doubt about it mike and i i mean look
we can talk about scheduling quirks
but i love you know after the raiders
game on sunday i talked to trent brown
okay and and you know obviously the
raiders look so good
uh for all but the third quarter of that
game in london legitimately justifiably
won that game were the better team
against the chicago bears
and now you look at it and say and i'm
gonna digress here for one second you
look at the whole scheduling issue
in the nfl and how outraged the raiders
were
while the raiders have gone to the
conquerors of the chiefs the
indianapolis colts and beat them and
then flown across the atlantic uh where
you by the way do not have a passport
and you are not allowed to go to london
so
they go and do this
and and they they now have won two in a
row
on this odyssey of a road trip this 43
days away
uh from oakland and and trent brown
basically said to me he goes hey listen
that's above my pay grade i don't care i
just we got 16 sundays or 16 whatevers
and i just go play the game and i i
gotta tell you
ignorance is bliss sometimes you know i
mean who what does it matter what you
think of the schedule once it's been
made who cares you shouldn't grouse
about it you ought to just go play it
and that is exactly what uh the oakland
raiders have done and that's what the
browns and the 49ers will have to do
this weekend with both of them having
very big games you know mike the 49ers
and the rams
is so is such an interesting match
starting with the coaches who are great
admirers of each other
and then going right to the quarterbacks
who both
you know obviously you're waiting to see
are they going to be
great nfl quarterbacks for a long period
of time they've both gotten paid like
that so far but we'll see which one or
both uh is actually going to turn out to
be great over a long period yeah this
has the chance to become a great great
rivalry when you look at the broader nfc
west picture with the seahawks in there
as well and we saw that great seahawks
rams game and there's a seahawks 49ers
game coming up on a monday night a few
weeks from now
this is a great round robin in that
division where you could have all three
of those teams possibly make it to the
postseason or maybe they cannibalize
each other enough where only one or two
can make it in but three great teams all
assigned to the same division all
jockeying for the same position and this
is desperation for the rams because and
the 49ers are not going to shrink in the
face of this they see the opportunity
they have they can deliver an early
knockout blow to the rams if they could
go down to la and win there and go to
5-0 and send the rams to 3-3 peter and i
think this 49ers team based upon what i
saw last night they're good enough to do
it
no question about it they're good enough
to do it because of defensive pressure
and you saw when richard sherman was
mic'd up last night mike where he was
going up and down the sidelines and he
goes
we cover y'all rush and he was saying
that to the defensive line and that is
the basic principle of what makes a
really good defense and right now
in my opinion when you look at you know
what you have i think both of these
teams can rush and both can cover
based on what i saw last night i mean
i've got a like right now with a very
slight edge to the san francisco 49ers
uh you know on the defensive side of the
ball
all right quick break when we return did
baker mayfield's biggest mistake on
monday night come before the game even
started we'll discuss that when pft live
continues right after this
[Music]
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports